hey youtube every year in Davos
Switzerland the world's top thinkers and
leaders gathered together for the World
Economic Forum discuss issues like
global poverty climate change energy the
hiv/aids crisis information technology
disaster relief corporate citizenship
economic development education and
global governance on the whole these
leaders are asking themselves how to
make the world a better place this year
you get to join them you can make your
voice heard in divorce by uploading a
video right here on YouTube with your
answer to the dadless question what one
thing do you think countries companies
or individuals should do to make the
world a better place in 2008 upload your
ideas on video and submit them right
here on YouTube starting January first
you'll be able to vote for the videos
that you like best some of the highest
rated clips will play it doubles in late
January in a special screening for
others in attendance and all the great
leaders and thinkers at Davos Bell
upward responses to your ideas so tell
everyone how you think we should make
the world a better place in 2008 you
never know your idea could be the start
of something back